hey guys it's a good I'm going to be
showing you guys how to shop at an Asian
grocery store to make it even more
special I'm bringing in Eric and
incredible chef today we picked sky
foods which is one of the biggest
grocery stores here in Flushing are
coming all the time he's the pro all
right let's go
[Music]
so where should we start
[Music]
you know key mushroom is really good
with just some butter and bacon pop it
in the oven
super good fresh tofu super fresh this
is Chinese cabbage good for stir fries
this is American cabbage it's really
good for clothes loss but this is where
it says sorry American cabbie for our
chicken sandwich we have a daikon slaw
that we use this pickle it with some
salt sugar and vinegar and it's amazing
on some fried chickens one of my
favorite dishes it's sweet potato leaves
stir fry steam went so much flavor you
don't really have to do anything to it
this is amazing
napa cabbage i love these so subtly
sweet and after you braise it for a
while it's got such a good texture and
they're super cheap water spinach hollow
center vegetable literal translation
this is what gives it texture the most
famous is the Malaysian style this front
piece and we can get that here too yes
we can get that here or any please these
are the stuff that I normally buy I lamb
that's how I fry them with Karl eggs
boiled them put some oyster sauce on it
they are so delicious and it's so good
these are dragon fruits it looks like a
like a sci-fi monster if you haven't
tried it please try it it's not super
sweet but it's really refreshing
this is guava Chris beard quencher than
apples dragon eyes literal translation
these are similar to lychee it's a
little bit sweeter okay combination we
can we can do Fitness it looks like this
but then there's like a little seed
inside I love it so these are finger
grapes they kind of look like fingers
texture is snappier than no grapes I
have never seen it every trip to the EJ
grocery store is an adventure love star
fruit they are literally stars my
favorite way of eating this is actually
just slice them up and peeling water
best-fit this one has a little
mercedes-benz crack it's rubber band so
it doesn't burst open it's a very
pungent smell
it's soft and pillowy and creamy custard
of nature
[Music]
different array of crimps and these are
tiger shrimps these guys have the best
texture of huge plans there's so much
fresh seafood a good indicator of fresh
fish is to see look at their eyeball
you don't want cloudy eyeballs so you
want clear eyeballs like this guy okay
these guys are extremely fresh probably
my favorite section in the entire
supermarket this is probably in my
opinion the most underrated cut it's
essentially like the shoulder cut by
braising and rice wine a lot of soy
sauce garlic aromatics scallion and it's
just incredibly tender
[Music]
this is the pantry that you need to have
popper onto a nonstick pan and five
minutes later you have something that's
close to you can't it constant a jaegers
you start and not check out the but ro
bun red bean paste toss allow roasted
pork fire they're super hungover the
next day you got these and your fridge
and you're all good that's how I got
through college really ice cream you put
them on go players mochi ice cream
handlebars right you an ice cream five
mini soft Serbs and matcha flavor
chocolate flavor of hounds ago so basic
I'm so basic how that ice cream right
here show me beat you more frozen food
then there's like normal food on the
other side this is my favorite soymilk
incredible flavors is the best I've had
in in New York so far the black sesame
version I'm sorry vocals
more bread tongue urine is like
glutinous yeah it's like hot mochi with
like filling on the inside right the
black sesame Tong
don't even bother with anything else
with this guy hey gal so if you guys
like dim sum shrimp dumplings steamed
this and you can eat dim sum at home
[Music]
this is all tea Oh mrs. tea oolong tea
Zen cha my mom used to get this for me
if I want a tea shop in turn Hatton has
less teeth in this everything is t- the
mushrooms sky foods shot the sky food
[Music]
all of this is dry noodle these noodles
are amazing and this lure is my favorite
they are not the cheapest but the fact
that you can get it here is crazy goo
this is definitely something I come in
try this
whoo X if I see
[Music]
this is actually the exact ran that I
use for water spinach it's really good
for stir-fry really any vegetable you
want there's also crab paste exact same
thing but with crabs kidney soy sauce
oyster sauce the ginger whatever you're
making a nice little there's your normal
soy sauce and then there's the dark soy
sauce normal soy sauce is more flavor
dark soy sauce is more color but both
are staples this is la cama aka the most
popular chili sauce it is also the
favorite sauce of John Cena
lot of chili sauce you actually said
that
[Music]
this whole aisle is my favorite section
a childhood classic or want long bean
rice crackers claw Oh shrimp crackers
this is all you need it's like those
shrimp trips but then in this french fry
form these are like little puffy
crackers corn soup couvert really good
this is a chick pea chick colored boy
it's spicy and it's really good
relatively portion controlled bag all
this is here so you don't have to worry
yeah oh yeah kimchi flavor ladies girls
squid flavor
if you like kettle corn you will like
this this is the brand I grew up with
shall we Shen I endorse hockey probably
one of the most popular agent snacks so
miss you I grew up with this at school
we have like a little tuck shop a little
snack shop this was the go-to snack look
there's even like an eel flavor
I don't feel about lobster flavor so
crazy
that concludes our Asian grocery store
haul I bought a lot of stuff I hope you
guys learned a lot today
don't be scared it's too breezy you'll
be back again next weekend probably
sooner
you